so with services and being a content
creator if you're putting yourself out
there and you're demonstrating your
skills you're marketing yourself the
good news is yes you can get paid ad
revenue and things like that to put
yourself out there and Market yourself
which is great the more important thing
is you are marketing yourself you're
bringing in these client relationships
so I did that as a freelancer now I get
to do it as a coach who helps other
content creators because by putting
myself out there demonstrating my
abilities my knowledge and my skills I
attract people who want to hire me that
kind of thing just opens up
opportunities because you're building
your network at scale because every
piece of content you put out Sean it's a
clone it's out there to build your
reputation build your relationships
generate Revenue while it's getting you
reach
so if you want to make a full-time
living as a Creator there are six
different business models and today
we're talking with Roberto Blake the
author of create something awesome and
he's going to break down just details
about these different business models so
you can pick the best one for you for
going part-time or full-time working
from home on your own schedule as a
Creator so Roberto welcome back to the
podcast and number one is services such
as freelancing and I know you've
personally walked through a lot of these
so break down some insights and kind of
tell us more about services and
freelancing sure absolutely so I
actually was able to do YouTube because
I had time Freedom Sean you know that
it's very hard for anyone to be a
full-time content creator when they also
have to work a full-time job or be a
full-time student time freedom is the
disproportionate advantage that content
creators have my time Freedom came from
the fact that I was a freelancer so as a
freelancer I was setting my own schedule
yes I had to find my own clients I had
to do everything myself that's kind of
the point you are you know working as a
mercenary at that point so you don't
have the backing of the company uh you
know there are advantages to being a
company man a company woman there's a
little bit of stability and security
there but for people that that's if it's
their personality or the lifestyle that
they want you can take on all the
responsibility that you had at your nine
to five job you can go ahead and say you
know what I'm going to go ahead I'm
going to save up money I'm gonna make
sure I have the same resources that the
nine to five job gives me in terms of my
software and my hardware and my setup
okay I'm gonna go up and I'm going to
build the client relationships so in my
case when I was working in corporate
they would bring in client relationships
I would do okay I'm gonna go ahead and
I'm gonna do this back end thing I'm
gonna do the website design or I'm going
to do the the print so I'm going to do
the graphic design I'm going to do this
I'm going to do that I'm going to set up
the back end I'm going to do the DNS I'm
going to do the tech I'm going to do
blah blah blah so okay in my mind I was
like you know what without poaching
clients from the company I can leave and
I can find people that I can deliver all
this value to because I'm servicing like
you know almost 100 of the corporations
customers plus a month well they all are
business owners I can be a business
owner just like them but more
importantly I can also just provide
value to all these other people who have
online businesses and this is years and
years ago this is like a decade ago like
wait a minute I can do this on my own I
can get the same I can get a better
computer than the company's giving me my
computer is out of date it's like oh
this is terrible that's easy oh this
software oh I can get software oh right
the licenses the software oh Adobe oh
that's easy so um I have this anyway I
would do this anyway so I went and I
made sure I had the resources I built my
own client relationships and I also had
to take on all the responsibility for
operations management
um just doing everything myself all the
liability and guess what that entitled
me to Sean all the revenue so now I cut
the employer of the equation so with
services and being a content creator if
you're putting yourself out there and
you're demonstrating your skills you're
marketing yourself because good news is
yes you can get paid ad revenue and
things like that to put yourself out
there and Market yourself which is great
but the more important thing is you are
marketing yourself you're bringing in
these client relationships so I did that
as a freelancer now I get to do it as a
coach who helps other content creators
because by putting myself out there
demonstrating my abilities my knowledge
and my skills I attract people who want
to hire me both in terms of coaching
clients but also in terms of brands that
hire me for sponsorship but also brands
that hire me for Consulting and events
that hire me for you know public
speaking we've spoken at many events
together would love to see you and speak
at uh go with video live it's been on my
list and that kind of thing just opens
up opportunities because you're building
your network at scale because every
piece of content you put out Sean it's a
clone it's out there to build your
reputation build your relationships
generate Revenue while it's getting you
reach so we have five other business
models but to go a little bit deeper in
the community that you coach what are
some of the services and freelance
services that people could offer to kind
of generate ideas if they don't have
maybe graphic design or web design or
video or photography like you or I some
of those skill sets what are some of the
other things you see people working from
home doing to create a little more
freedom so they can also build their
YouTube channels this is perfect a lot
of people work as virtual assistants and
they do admin work so that's
extraordinarily powerful and you can
bring a lot of diverse things to the
table there almost anyone can do that
and you can learn the skills that make
you a great admin overnight some people
do Community Management uh you know Andy
Rivera who works with me as my
operations manager one of the big tasks
on her plate is the Community Management
so if you can do Community Management
you can do operations uh planning
there's also people who do customer
service for example Melissa who works on
your team they're people who do admin
work and customer service there's people
who do automations manage email list you
could also do writing you know Common or
have a wonderful team that write for the
published press and they basically just
get to work primarily as editors and
like get to oversee that and do a little
curation but the actual writing is done
by the wonderful people on their team so
there's that aspect of it there's also
sales positions you have a great sales
team over at think media so I think that
there are a variety of opportunities for
people and it doesn't just go down to
technical skills you can use soft skills
and scale those online as well yeah
that's powerful and again we're talking
about the six main business models of
the Creator economy and one of the ways
to get into working in the Creator
economy is to work for another
established Creator it's also one of the
best ways to get proximity learn for
maybe one day wanting to launch your own
thing that's something we've done here
at think media is some people we
recognize maybe want to roll with us
forever or maybe they want to just be a
part of building the company here and
the vision here for a while but
eventually they want to launch their own
thing and they want to absorb those
skills it can be really smart for
linking up up with people and also if
you ever want to check out what's
happening at think work with think.com
and we'll put that in the show notes is
where we have our open positions and
things like that but secondly is
royalties from ad revenue or
intellectual property explain some of
these Insider terms yes so a lot of
people don't realize that the ad Revenue
that we get from YouTube and these
Creator funds and so on is uh taxed as a
royalty income now for more tax advice
get yourself a certified public
accountant or professional this is not
Financial advice for entertainment
purposes only
um so disclaimers aside
the classification of this income is
royalty income and that's because it
fits the best uh historical subset of
how creative Services people have been
paid because when you hear royalties
usually that's likened to authors who
write books like you know like we do you
know we write books we get royalties uh
musicians of course but also also
performance royalties and you can also
get royalties sometimes when you work
with companies and Brands because
sometimes they can license the usage of
either your content or even maybe your
face or if you have some intellectual
property that you've trademarked and
they want a shareable license with that
you can license those terms they could
be in perpetuity they can be for a
limited time that they write you a check
for that for the usage uh or there could
be Revenue sharing associated with that
or it's a percentage
etc etc or it could be a fixed fee this
also happens if you do performance
royalties when you uh do a a skit or
something on a TV show and if it's in
syndication you'll still see royalty
checks from that
um fairly sure iJustine still
um gets a check for the episode she was
in on Law and Order SVU you know so
there's so there's all these
opportunities with this a lot of people
also don't realize you can get royalty
licensing for intellectual property
around things like your photography if
you license the these to stock media
websites like story blocks and you also
of course could do streaming royalties
like Harris Heller does with stream
Beats so there's or if you're a
published musician not just someone
creating stock media but if you're a
public musician like KSI or Gabby Hannah
or any of the other YouTube musicians
after Lindsey Stirling so on so forth so
royalties exist across multiple
platforms where you can make money
obviously you and I get royalties from
Amazon because of Kindle Direct
publishing because we're both published
authors and so a lot of people just
think oh YouTube ad Revenue no you can
get paid for your intellectual property
across multiple multiple platforms
whether that's through ad Revenue
Creator funds or licensing powerful and
definitely things people don't think
about number three is a little bit more
known but break down some insights on
affiliate marketing which is getting
sales commissions from products and
services
I love affiliate marketing I know a lot
of people have some skepticism I think
that a lot of people here affiliate
marketing and they think scam and that's
because they're confusing it with MLM
multi-level marketing which has a very
dubious reputation and not even all of
those I believe
um based on technical legal definitions
are uh scams or whatever but you know
some of them clearly are the thing with
affiliate marketing is it should be
obvious to everybody because of Amazon
and Amazon's influencer marketing that
there is legit affiliate marketing and
the easiest legit affiliate marketing is
the type that you and I do it's
typically things like the Amazon
influencer program where people buy
Hardware so they buy physical tangible
items from the biggest retail store in
the world you get a percentage now you
and I also as Veterans of that know that
it's only two to eight percent depending
on the category so it's not it's it's
nice at scale and it's nice depending on
what category you go into you make more
selling Amazon's products you make more
selling Electronics uh things like that
and then it gets lower when you're doing
books uh if you do Amazon's own fashion
brand it does well so uh it just depends
on the opportunity but with the thing
that I like the most is software as a
service affiliate and that's also very
good and uh legitimate in both cases
you're just getting a commissions on
whatever sales you make for the company
and imagine if for your nine to five
employer imagine saying hey you know
what Sean we're going to give you 20 of
every dollar that you've ever made for
the company how's that sound shot like
it's great here's the problem Oh but you
have to give up a salary oh well that
okay that's not so great because
security like okay it's make it take it
but when you have other revenue streams
in play whether it's the services you're
providing ad revenue is stable or
something else then this percentage
thing starts to sound really really good
and with software it can be recurring
monthly Revenue which is how it really
can replace a salary and so my biggest
affiliate is our friends over at
tubebuddy and with tubebuddy I
consistently make somewhere between four
thousand and six thousand dollars a
month never less than 4 000 highest is a
little over six uh I make that
consecutively a month and have for many
many years now I believe in the years
that I've been with tubebuddy I think
it's been maybe five or six years now
and I think uh I've hit 350 to 400 000
Lifetime with them and I do four
thousand six thousand dollars a month
for a lot of people that's a livable
income by itself but it's for work I've
already done because I don't have to do
much to keep those customers as long as
they're happy with the software I will
always be paid for building the
relationship with a client because I
have the uh the investment and the
return from the relationship in
perpetuity so I'm earning from those
relationships in perpetuity
um as a brand ambassador and an
affiliate and uh through the Goodwill
that I have in the community that it
takes a lot of pressure off son and
that's really good and the best part
about it is if someone cancels I don't
make money if they keep it I make money
so the legitimacy of affiliate marketing
is just a matter of people understanding
what it is understanding real value
that's created with products and
services and for me you don't get much
more legit than hardware and software
because anyone can refund Hardware that
they don't like in 30 days with Amazon
pretty much no questions asked as long
as they ship it back and anyone can
cancel software anytime they want if
they're not using it anymore so I don't
think there's any way for anyone to
really get hurt on that at all because
if you don't like something you can
refund it or cancel it so no harm no
foul and for creating and providing that
value to the company they're happy to
pay a commission because it's in many
cases a cheaper way to guarantee the
sale than for them to buy traditional
advertising uh so that's you know that's
how I utilize affiliate marketing and I
think it's one of the best underrated
opportunities for most people yeah I
agree and one of our definitions is
affiliate marketing is a cool way to
share products you personally love and
use that you would naturally recommend
to friends or family anyways but to make
a commission in the process that doesn't
make the product costs anymore and what
these companies know is is that they're
not doing paid advertising their cost of
acquisition is wrapped into your
commission as opposed to having to
advertise somewhere else or put up a
billboard or advertising a trade
magazine or buy a booth at a convention
they're empowering the Creator to earn
money on that transaction and what's
cool is if you're new to affiliate
marketing there's literally everything I
mean Dick's Sporting Goods Bass Pro
Shops Walmart Best Buy targets
yeah and of course software as you
mentioned our friend Pat Flynn uh
similar to your tubebuddy results has
done that with like email marketing
stuff convertkit or activecampaign or
one of those and so
um it's a huge opportunity and one of
the best ways to get started because you
don't have to create anything yourself
you just make content that's helpful and
they do all the heavy lifting to your
point of customer service returns
helping you know the creation of the
product literally everything so even if
commissions are low so is also the
maintenance in the work side if you can
just create the content but that brings
us to number four out of our six
business models of the Creator economy
which was e-commerce so selling either
digital or physical products online
explain this in some examples sure so we
all utilize e-commerce now we're all
buying physical or digital goods online
every time uh you know I go into a video
game and I do all of that uh wonderful
DLC or any of those in uh game or in-app
purchases of making digital you know
purchases and spending real money for uh
digital Goods it's like it's not some
new thing I know people like to think
that that's some nude weird thing no
we've been doing that for like 20 years
now like at least as Gamers have we've
been doing that for 20 years so like so
that's uh that's interesting and then
when it comes to physical products we
obviously most of us buy things from
Amazon or any of our other favorite
stores and have it shipped to us Best
Buy
um you know Walmart a lot of us are
doing doing all of this online shopping
you know regardless of what time of year
it is year round and so we should be
less skeptical about this concept
because we literally have been doing it
for like last 10 15 years all of us why
are we ourselves only being consumers
when it comes to the e-commerce side why
hasn't occurred to any of us to
productize ourselves uh condense our
value either an experience or knowledge
or something or even our skill as a
craftsperson into something that allows
us to sell online at scale so I've been
doing this with digital products like my
YouTube starter kit my brand deal
starter kit not an online course yet
although you can definitely do that uh I
have like courses coming uh soon uh you
know but the thing that everyone thinks
about is online course but no you could
be doing notion templates like Thomas
Frank Thomas Frank I think is getting
close to making seven figures from
notion 10th plates around productivity
systems that he's developed and there's
a lot of people making millions of
dollars in the notion Community doing
that our friend Pat Flynn has a physical
product in e-commerce that he developed
the switch pod which helps content
creators and vloggers as competition for
the Joby GorillaPod so really powerful
things that you could do he solved his
own problem of I need something uh you
know uh thinner lighter and more stable
than the Shelby GorillaPod of Joby
gorillapod's great I have nothing
against it but what about just having a
different option so he and his um you
know friend Caleb
um you know another wonderful content uh
Creator developed this product I was one
of the first people to ever touch hold
it give recommendations and feedback at
uh vidsummit years and years ago and
it's been a historic uh product in the
ecosystem a friend and client of mine a
drive he's launching his own collectible
card game he's huge in the Pokemon
Community hit a million subscribers
recently we've done like four coaching
calls together over the last couple of
years and everything uh he developed one
we helped actually with the Bell
development of his merchandise brand
that um like did I think they had a year
where they did like 500k uh merch drop
and it's around this concept because
he's a Shiny Pokemon hunter uh we hit it
with Team shiny as a brand and we
figured out the concept of collectible
merch like merch where there's an
overlap with a collectible theme because
we're talking to a Pokemon Community now
he has his own trademark intellectual
property with his card game elestials
and so uh it's been one of the
historically quickest and most backed
kicks first time first time Kickstarter
projects of all time so uh tremendous
stuff there this means that between
using platforms like I use kajabi as you
do for our online digital products
memberships and courses you can use
Shopify for something to ship out
physical products and things of that
nature some people do merch by Amazon
for merchandise some people do
spreadshop because it cost them zero
dollars so there's all these ways to
sell and do e-commerce and sell your own
product directly to your audience
whether it's physical most people's
physical product will be merch some
people will be more ambitious and will
make camera accessories or card games
and then you can have digital products
that could be template systems uh in
Photoshop notion uh preset let packs
like Peter McKinnon or it could be
online digital courses yeah this is
powerful and I think this is you could
almost call this one of the strategies
that's more advanced or one that comes a
little bit later in the journey I think
what's amazing about the crater economy
is there's ways to start immediately
with like affiliate marketing as you get
monetized on YouTube now ad Revenue
could be coming in freelancing is a
great way to trade your time for money
but still create more freedom right when
you're starting but for everybody
listening to this it's something to
dream about think about the inspiration
might not strike you immediately but be
thinking about how can you
take back the the strongest place of
power in your own brand which is
creating something that you own that's
either digital or physical that you can
sell I've heard it said that your income
is directly correlated to the amount of
buy buttons on your website
which may trigger you to think shoot I
don't even have a website
number two I don't have any buy buttons
and and then you think number three
that's maybe why my income is capped and
that speaks to again these are things
that are going to be taking your brand
off of Amazon taking your brand off of
YouTube to a point you're creating
something of your own you're using
YouTube maybe as a marketing channel
you're building an email list but
eventually you're able to sell something
and therefore you're also able to reap
the rewards you're not getting two to
eight percent on Amazon but make an
online course you're gonna flip it
you're gonna make like 98 besides your
two percent stripe fee and uh
and so the but it takes a lot of work
and so you don't have to do all of this
at once it takes time to create a good
product that you want to stand behind uh
but definitely something that should be
in your queue so those are four of six
number five is brand deals like
sponsorships from promoting Brands and
anybody listening to this by now has
heard podcasts sponsored by purple
mattress or or seen YouTube videos
brought to you by Squarespace but break
down some of your stuff and I know this
is a deep vertical of expertise for you
you've got some education content
specifically on brand deals and so we
could do a whole episode about this and
that's one reason uh we'll Link in the
show notes your book create something
awesome uh for more tactical tips but do
a summation of of some tactical stuff on
brand deals so one of the funny things
is uh that I think that affiliate
marketing and brand deals are like you
know big and little brother here you
know and it's either once whichever one
pays you more is the Big Brother uh but
the thing is
you could use your affiliate marketing
stats to actually help you negotiate
better brand deals because you actually
are able to prove the buying power of
your audience and so now it's less
theoretical so you're reducing the risk
for a brand so that's one thing the
other thing you have to understand that
a lot of things is like when you're
dealing with Brands it's about risk
reach reputation and revenue and so one
of the things you want to do is you want
to qualify that you're low risk part of
that is having a good reputation keeping
your you know content in your community
as clean as possible if you're not and
you're a little edgier you have to
understand that that limits your brand
opportunities and you have to act
accordingly you have to also recognize
okay when it comes to reach I have to
demonstrate that Outreach so maybe that
is demonstrated in my uh numbers in my
vanity metrics but sometimes you could
re-contextualize that reach and say hey
I don't have the largest number in the
world but I have such a deep reputation
with the people that I do reach that
they buy myself so and thing is to prove
that you have to either approve that in
my opinion with either your affiliate
Marketing sales or your own product
sales you can prove that in terms of my
reputation generates revenue and here's
how I can prove it so don't negotiate on
your reach negotiate on holistically on
reach reputation risk and revenue and
say Here's how I'm going to reduce some
risk for you those are things you can
talk about in the pitch or in the
contract here is how we're going to
reach people together here's how I
enhance your reputation here's how you
benefit from my reputation by having an
advocate in the community with me as a
brand ambassador and how I represent you
and then here is how you're going to get
Revenue here is what's going to justify
the price that I'm charging you I am
considering what is uh appropriate and
what is helpful to you I'm not just
trying to extract value from you without
giving you anything back so there's a
respect aspect to that uh relationship
and so when we work with Brands when
we're doing sponsored content they're
not just paying us for oh you have this
many subscribers here's the amount of
money you get now here's the views you
get here's the amount of money you get
that is the weakest form of negotiation
tactically with Brands I want every
Creator to do an internal audit and not
only look at their numbers and know
their reach and then stop trying to sell
on that I want them to look at their
reputation and your reputation isn't
just how people feel about you in the
community it's a reputation for the
quality of the work that you do so what
you represent in yourself or your
reputation is here is how we make a
video if you're you know Marquez Bradley
it's like we make videos that are
impossible to replicate and duplicate
anyone can talk an iPhone but people do
not have the shots we do people don't go
in depth we do they don't come up with a
script and the ideas that we do so the
body of work your reputation that
quality why am I shooting in 4k why do I
have this lighting why have it's because
it will improve my reputation for high
quality high value content that will be
not outdated and will stay competitive
in the future whenever someone sees this
and hears the Brand's name that I'm in a
relationship with so there's that aspect
it's also about paying for the access to
your reputation to use your name and say
that hey I'm approved by Sean I'm
approved by Justine I'm approved by
Roberto I'm approved by Marquez as a
brand you add legitimacy
um to a brand now a lot of creators
smaller content creators think that they
need to do brand deals because in their
mind they're looking for legitimacy with
their peers by doing that and respect
from the community by doing that and a
lot of times they undervalue themselves
because they're looking for that or
sometimes they end up taking bad deals
that they shouldn't they actually hurt
their reputation because they're trying
to prove themselves I think what you
have to do is respect the relationship
you have with your audience
put them first in everything that you do
and then really feel that when you do
this you're mitigating your risk to your
reputation associating with a brand as
well so these are the things that I try
to coach creators on when I work with
them and we talk about brand deals
specifically because you already know
this the things I'm talking about is not
what most people talk about whenever you
watch a video about sponsored content so
powerful insights and I definitely
recommend uh if you haven't followed
Roberto over he's got deeper content on
his YouTube channel on brand deals and
there's a lot to say there but really
powerful
um tips on brand deals which was number
five out of the six main business models
of the crater economy now of course
what's wild about the greater economy is
there's
More Than This there are there's new
opportunities coming up people are
expressing creativity
um and it's inspiring to see people
they're launching businesses they're
spinning off other companies but these
are the six main business models and a
really good starting point for really
understanding monetization even being
able to make a plan and talk to your
family I think that sometimes it's hard
to enlist you may feel like you're under
supported by a spouse or a family member
because they say well that's not really
a real job there's not a practicality to
this no this is the fastest growing
small business type but it's important
to understand the mechanics and the
different ways that you can combine or
that you can also isolate and go deep on
and so we've covered these first five
but number six Roberto's memberships
monthly recurring payments from an
audience what are some of your insights
here yes so this one I really like
because I think that if you're looking
for stability when we talk about people
like people who work a regular job nine
to five a lot of times they're getting
paid twice a month
for one thing if you diversify your
income streams in the Creator economy
and you have these multiple streams of
income you're getting paid more than the
twice a month so actually you could
argue very easily that if you're doing
it from the perspective that we talk
about and correctly there's like more
stability actually than less it's just
up front there's less but if you're
doing it correctly very quickly you
could have much much more and the thing
is the disruption to your income if you
work a nine to five job and you're and
that's your sole source of income and
you and I both experienced this and
we're survivors the last recession
um and so we've been fired before we
understand that it's like that security
and stability lies in one person one
supervisor one manager can make a
decision through no fault of your own
and say your income's gone so what
stability people are imagining I don't
know I think that that's been bad
marketing I think it's cap but as the
kids would say now that being uh said
once you get to a point to where you
have your your own membership website
membership Community or whether that you
did that in platform if you do it in
platform you split the revenue with a
platform if it's YouTube it's 30 if it's
other platforms it could be more than 50
percent if you have your own website
like you and I do hosted through kajabi
not sponsored
um then you could set your rates and
then you're not splitting a percentage
it's just your service fees to stripe
paypals or processors and then your bank
and then after that the real fun of is
splitting it with the government through
taxes um so that's where um their
percentage ends up being closer to
YouTube's so the um so the thing about
that is you can have more top line
revenue coming in but the other great
thing about this is if you own the
system that's not even a monthly payout
it's cash flow which means you're
getting that upfront on the days that
people pay which means you could be
literally if you have if you have
members if you have a hundred members
and they all signed up on different days
if you own your own platform that money
is going to your striper PayPal across
those different days which means you
could have cash that comes in Daily
because of this which is also another
good cash flow thing with uh selling
your own products uh but unlike selling
your own products this is basically
guaranteed recurring income as long as
you do not churn these customers as long
as these people do not cancel you're
getting that 59 a month or that 29 a
month or that 99 a month every single
month for however many people are signed
up so once you have a hundred people
signed up in this kind of model you have
livable guaranteed income comparable to
a job that's also more stable in terms
of its cash flow because unlike your
YouTube check that comes in on the 21st
that's not a once a month thing unlike
your payout on your royalties on your
book that's not a once a month thing
this is continuous
um payments that are going up throughout
incrementally that cash flow and add up
and you have a very good Overlook of the
guaranteed source of income the other
thing is you can always get more members
so it could go up and it can scale so as
long as you're maintaining people you're
not churning them you're not losing them
you actually have a more stable source
of income than many of the ones we
talked about and when you combine it
with those other sources of income when
you have recurring affiliate marketing
uh money and that's monthly recurring
income it's once a month per affiliate
program so if you have three four really
decent affiliate programs oh wow that
ends up being a lot more stability there
are more pillars here to
um Shore things up and keep them uh you
know stable build a really strong
Foundation financially and then with
this I think memberships is one because
what memberships is the thing you
control you control that asset you own
that intellectual property you own that
website and so the rules aren't going to
just change on you the platforms aren't
going to code switch on you change
policies have delays have excuses so on
so forth so that's the other added layer
of stability because you can have
problems with your nine to five job it
can be fired it could be payroll delays
it could be any number of things that
could disrupt your income over there
could be an industry thing could be
beyond your control so I don't think the
narrative that you have all these
assurances with traditional work Stacks
up when you analyze it and that's part
of why I wrote a book about this Sean I
wrote a book partly even so people
pursuing this have a way to kind of
defend themselves when they're having
these conversations because they have
the arguments laid out for them and the
facts and the data to back it up but
also to give them a practical plan so
they don't keep thinking that they're
crazy or thinking that they're
delusional they have a practical
actionable framework to build off of and
they can do that whether they're doing
regular YouTube style uh medium form
content short form content live
streaming podcasting there's a variety
of ways to approach it but by learning
good business principles learning
Concepts like mrr monthly recurring
Revenue understanding concepts like
churn customer acquisition and retention
you're going to put yourself in a
position to do this seriously and to be
taken seriously while you're doing it
[Music]